[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talk about whatever we want and
today we have Paco here he's a youtuber
who he says is trying to do stand-up
he's trying really hard
professional Kotel writer the Bueller is
Wertheim and we stole him from Ryan
chica we did screw that guy
what do you mean by a professional Kotel
right Oh Ryan Higa T's used him to get
famous yeah yeah but also getting paid
but even before Ryan I was working for
our wasabi productions oh you know the
dirt together yeah yeah when they were
together I was the reason they broke up
really no we don't know I would believe
you yeah I know I'm a great loss when I
met you could be I do remember I
actually forgot that you were a part of
the Ryan Higa scant mm-hmm I juice very
forgettable of the videos yeah cuz he's
like a nobody but like you know we met I
met you and is a right I was like oh
this guy's [ __ ] dope and and we're
just like talking yeah and then I'm like
I like this guy and I'm like won't you
come on
just kidding News and then you start
talking about how you worked with Ryan
and all this and I was like yeah name
Rob I do remember you I do remember you
in like the Mafia games and all the
stuff that they would play that's where
I saw you from what I hear - yeah cuz
they copied our Channel no no no get it
right we got beside min okay yeah people
get way more views than you but but the
thing is I invited his ass before I knew
about the whole like he's a part of
their group oh damn that means not my
legitimate Ness then huh my legitimate
nespa you were actually liked maybe one
can we get Ryan I mean like he only
really does stuff for like relevant
people so
laughing over here good luck good luck I
have his number does that count a lot of
people have his number yeah funny thing
is like we've known him for a long time
but we never got close with them but
that's a lot of people on YouTube though
yes that's true
you're like friends but it's like you
get all know that you're busy but you
can't really like you know have that
time to get close Susie all the time 24
hours nobody I am I want to see anyway
what you don't say that's what I'm
saying yeah that's true that's true but
it's like also you nobody thinks you're
that busy nobody you want time to wind
down yeah and also we're all the way in
Vegas so oh yeah that's yeah when I'm
there I'm not trying to meet you guys
I'm trying to get exactly you're trying
to have fun you're not trying to have
fun with friends
nope did you know that Vegas is his
promised land yeah that's where I
believe that you can live as my friend
Bart says like a rapper for very cheap
it's true tell them about your apartment
do I have a two-bedroom apartment for
1,400 see that's beautiful amenities
dude I get a monthly massage and [ __ ]
it's great
Enrique is amazing what's the square
footage I think it's like 12 to 14 huh
that's like my house bow that's nice
I'll pay 4000 a month oh that's a
passport
I'll buy yourself and you don't even get
in Enrique dude I don't and I have to
massage and clean myself I knew what you
were getting at thank you Joe
I like it when I when I get this yeah
you come in because I don't get
attention so when I get attention that's
what I'm like again oh actually do you
feel like the reason why you kind of
like got into comedy and stuff like that
and I guess this could be for everybody
is because you didn't get certain
attention that you feel like you wanted
as a kid oh man
this is fine you know also this is like
a me too thing so you might want to move
canceled right there go she did the
[ __ ] this one and it didn't move no
no no I'm a bit clawed a little but we
did it call I love it straight no that
was to knuckle let's zoom in all right
Minority Report zoom with all that [ __ ]
dude I looked I do think that comedy is
an awesome coping mechanism but it does
come from a dark place yeah I have
rarely met a really funny person that's
had a really good childhood uh-huh
yeah you know what I mean like name one
everyone that's had a great childhood
that tries to go into comedy they're not
funny they saw what happened to you
Steve well my buddy had a great
childhood he always talks about how he
wants to be accepted by his father
there's two versions of me right there's
Tommy which to you guys I'm always like
my parents was the tire like so tight I
mean my dad would hug me too hard and
sometimes it would choke me a little bit
right and then there's the other version
of me worried I sometimes I talk about
the real [ __ ] and I know it's to tell
you cuz hilarious you just plan whatever
stereotype of because if we're talking
about how we got we got beat he's
playing the role of all I'm so white and
I'm so you know you know they said to me
yeah we have to fill the role you full
on yeah yeah but but sometimes it's
funny cuz on my podcast with Nicki that
we get somebody wrote in and they're
like hey I know that you had such a
great upbringing because they saw me on
JK parents no I'm saying that they saw
me say down yeah and yeah so I it was
one of those things where I'm like oh
[ __ ] like because I troll so hard they
don't really she yeah see now you know
how I feel when I'm trying to like
actually tell her mom like a real story
and then I'm on the verge of breaking
and crying and she these are you [ __ ]
with me I'm like no I'm like are you
trying to blame it on my mom I know
he was laughing at me when I was
explaining that when I pour my heart out
to Stephen well it's just funny cuz your
cuz I picture you actually pouring your
heart out yeah and then just getting
laughed at which is funny yeah even when
I think about funny it is and I feel for
him cuz I'm like oh yeah he's really
trying to connect that my mom's like get
that [ __ ] catch up
we were driving with her mom and then
we're trying to kind of convince her to
like move in with us and just to be a
part of the family and I was telling her
that when I was six my parents got
divorced I'm the only child so my
family's just really lonely and then
like I started thinking about like man
like tyke has a way better than I'll
ever have and yes around his eyes
getting kind of like you know I'm like
looking at at her like you know it'd be
really cool this means a lot to me and
I'm like I think I probably loved it as
much as I love my old mom
and there's like a little bit of silence
and she goes are you have a question
though is the author record segment
about the guest the guest is boring we
have to go I took one on the chin all
right that's cool no joke you have a
good joke I'll write it down or if you
guys have a good joke stealing jokes
I'll spill your guys that's what YouTube
has come to what's up the first time it
happened really though the gene hat on
my oh it's a bucket hat keeps all my
ideas from being stolen
okay you guys don't even know but I'm
wearing it backwards I'm edgy nobody's
gonna steal your fashion bro you'll be
fine thank you thank you I wish you
could have some to steal I die I have no
fashion I'm very famous for that no
fashion no cars no tapes you skip the
teen years and went straight to dad yeah
I mean look at my hair dude he went
straight there cuz he didn't have a good
relationship with his gaudy oh no my dad
has plenty of his hair and I envied him
for in him for it and loathe him good
for you
your dad has good hair he does I think
your hair is cool
let's not go crazy here these that
occurred a little bit smile
hey papa did you grow up here in LA no I
grew up in Hawaii oh yeah Oh wahoo
oh sure like the like Waipahu so near
Pearl Harbor basically oh my people bond
yeah and then they left before Japanese
yeah I'm half Japanese I'm half Japanese
half Filipino oh cool
yeah so I'm a dirty mix you know nobody
really cleans so you're like oh so
you're like on time but they're not on
time yeah
like I'll show up on time and then sit
in my car on my phone for a bit yeah
that's what I do how do you like living
how do you like living here versus like
living over there it's way more
expensive over there yeah cuz everything
has to be imported like milk is eight
dollars a gallon
oh yeah they don't they have three jobs
they drink almond milk that's you but
also that's why I like so many families
have like like everybody living in one
house oh it's a necessity yeah almost I
just found out this if your household
makes like ninety one thousand dollars
that's considered low income in Hawaii
yeah there's probably three families and
yeah and it's expensive to live there or
is it actually I think I'll always like
one of the cheaper Oh because everything
goes to oh and then has to be imported
out even more to the other islands I'll
be making all this [ __ ] up I don't know
but it sounds correct
I came people I can't believe that
people vacation in Waikiki because I
don't like it that much
yeah yeah it's a fake Beach actually is
it really yeah they imported all the
sand to there it's telecourse
that's why underneath if you like start
digging usually they like secure like uh
lifeguards or whatever they tell you
stop because like you're gonna get show
like concrete and all that everything
yes its fake its fake I'd like to it's
Wow well that that sounds coming now
like I think it was just like coral and
all broken up and then they for the
tourism they would bring a [ __ ] ton of
sand because that's where all the first
hotels were yeah bring the beach there
that's why
than the other beaches are real all
right oh yeah like the like makhmour
North Shore all that yeah and it's like
super nice but North Shore is like kind
of expensive to live because like it's
like where all the surfers go to
practice all the events are held over
there but I mean I parent this time we
went around um our local friends took us
like toured electrics and in the West
Side and then that was nothing but
straight like Hawaiians and locals and
oh yeah because that's like Waianae and
yeah it was that area like yeah I was
like someone with your skin complexion
came over there
you get stink eyes that's what I really
yeah yeah like they're they really don't
like white people we go Steve don't go
no I want to see what I want to see
Steve get aroused hey wouldn't work very
well I don't I don't really get angry
people things like that I know yeah cuz
he's used to it yeah well then if that's
the case you might be they might like
you oh there you go yeah if they like
try to attack you in your sleep
yeah whatever hey hey guys no no I'm
warning you guys huh yeah miss the beach
like it's fun
I mean desert yeah yeah it's fun until
you have to like walk back to your car
and then all the sand gets stuck to you
and then you bring it into your car dude
I know it's super too small but that's
the one thing I was always like this is
so annoying
but there's a showers too no yeah but no
you should gets in there and then when
you have to walk to your car you're
kicking up sand onto your legs and
everything so here's what here's my
questions like why is there so many
locals in Las Vegas the ton of Hawaiians
there I think um it's due to a couple of
different things like where do you
vacation if you live in paradise you
know they can't use asparagus no no if
you live in Hawaii which is paradise
yeah you want to go to some place that's
like Sin City we and then you don't
gambling and all ego in Hawaii yeah
actually there's a lot of gambling
houses that just got caught oh but also
I think at the same time when it was
starting like they had a lot of good
specials or cuz California hotel
yeah and planes would like fly you out
and you can stay there they
accommodate a lot of games so I think
Hawaiians just started going a lot more
just because it was convenient it was
cheaper and then it just became a thing
like let's just go here they just skip
LA and go straight to Vegas what blows
my mind is you come from the most
wettest part of America to the driest
part yeah and that's crazy cuz just
living in LA going to Vegas it Vegas
alone is too crazy for me if I stay for
over three four days I feel like they
just sucked everything out of me my
[ __ ] money my [ __ ] like moisture
my nut everything yeah it's like how the
[ __ ] I'm sorry for that no but how do
you survive because you come from a
super dude I thought about that series
cuz I actually lived in LA before I
moved to V mmm nas like man I could
never live in Vegas and then I saw the
rent prices and I was like I could live
in vain yes please that's true when I
look at the rain or like yeah housing
I'm just like Vegas is such an awesome
all I'm just throwing this out there cuz
Ryan always pitches this to people like
oh you should move out to Vegas no
income tax yeah big yeah I'm with you
guys
up until I look at the Google Maps right
and I see the house I'm like Danis tie
it and then i zoom out and it's like a
pocket of houses and it's like nothing
but isn't that an awesome
what is where are you right now geo
[ __ ] same [ __ ] don't they don't care
what I'm just saying it's the same idea
I know that's so true but I have my mom
they also expanding they're also
expanding to putting up a lot more stuff
now it sounds like you've given this
pitch a few times like I have not I've
just heard Ryan give it and I'm just
regurgitating in Fredonia s-- because
you're decided didn't like it geo I
think I'm traumatized by a Vegas Joe
helped me uncover that cuz uh my mom
yeah my mom would always take us to
Vegas it was a bad experience yeah and
then when we would go like we had to
wait in the lobby it was so [ __ ]
boring because they're gambling they
were like nothing about the strip but
I'm gonna leave Henderson or like that's
a childhood association to it
I've got you our God is in it he just
met me five minutes ago see a real bit
real bit really our biggest trips right
just call me back well beeping our
biggest trips she never really even
played in gambling so it was until
Brandon started playing craps with them
and renamed well cuz I love gambling and
I always want people to play and then so
if not everyone's on board it cuts the
gambling short so I'm trying to get
everyone addicted to gambling before we
came to the goal no cuz we went there a
couple times before Brandon but you made
it really fun okay it already likes rats
so that's when they got into church so
you love bro it wasn't you at all about
Treasuries and look no no I know but I
just want to give it to Nicky because I
can't handle it real or bit real or bit
really oh you don't you don't spend all
your money on the tables oh dude I did
and then I was like oh I gotta stop see
I think I'd be on there but I wouldn't
tell myself to stop that would be an
interesting paycheck habit right like
you get your check and then you go to a
cuz you know and then you play a little
bit yeah yeah building like the people
who work at casinos like the tips they
make a lot of the times they'll just try
and like double down real quick like as
they're leaving they'll just be like
betting on black yeah a lot of the
dealer's you know when you tip um yeah
they just go always better for me yeah
yeah exactly
don't you just want to collect as you're
working take this home but there's
laters better for me and they're like
Savin out who wants their tip leave the
table expression on their face after the
same darkness yeah good comedians
actually that's true yeah alright so
that's true some of them are yeah I
would seriously entertained Vegas if we
could get her family to come up like if
my mom would be down brother work out
there used to he did but his wife
doesn't want to move out there because
she's got a bunch of family out here
whatever you guys are already breaking
ground my sister-in-law's family and
then everyone can move you already
broken ground at least one her mom to
come you're already breaking ground in
your dream backyard so I'm sure you'll
be keeping Vegas open
yeah how fast would you actually make
that decision make what decision how
entertain the thought and do it quickly
we move fast we move pretty fast no once
you use things like this is we found our
forever home our forever home our
forever home on everything I'm like yeah
they're moving to Vegas sure it for long
the minute her mom is down to mobilize
it's different game or G oh by the way
Gia
just so you know real poppy real you
know you said like no statements all
questions this whole time yeah so what
is your favorite or worse experience
from Vegas um my favorite has to be with
everyone like we we always take Vegas
trips together and I think it was that
one time where it was just Bart geojo me
and Casey that was fun that's the best
trip there's no Steve no Nikki no Susie
because we got stoned yeah all that time
actually the best and the worst at the
same time why what was it what was Casey
and I had some real problems then but
that was a great moment as a group okay
that was my favorite even though it was
day it was actually thank you guys
that's so funny because we joined in
your trip cuz you guys got that free
weekend for that [ __ ] timeshare that
you got stuck do with getting a lawyer
like figuring it I'm just like whatever
just you showed us to to try to like
help us convince you you like isn't this
nice guys
they're like yeah but it's so [ __ ]
far away from all the casinos so that
one was a separate time sure not the one
I actually have it was this other time
sure trying to get us to get the
timeshare we were already smart by then
we're like we're not hanging up but
we're getting this free lontel room like
we're not sign up for this we're getting
the one in the North Pole that's gonna
be sick yes
you know what the dumbest thing ever is
it's not even a timeshare it's [ __ ]
points for a vacation club it's the
worst game ever don't ever play into any
of those it's stupid we don't even have
a timeshare oh yeah you don't even get
the time to say you have a timeshare
yeah I don't even use good vacation
points but it was thanks to you getting
that deal that's actually the same
[ __ ] thing that led us to the Hawaii
trip the first Hawaii trip with all of
us together it was because we were
supposed to get a free Hawaii troduce aw
that [ __ ] billboard that said wanna
go to Hawaii for free no it wasn't bad
oh god yes your guys's foolishness
allows for great stories and coming
together fail more and create more
mistakes cuz that's the best friends
that are ridiculous yeah that's right
Tonya don't use protection use 14 year
old Wow what the [ __ ] done this message
you said have mistakes with your friends
this is a wonder why why well honestly
in Hawaii when I graduated this girl in
my graduating class had three kids by
the time yeah we have like [ __ ] ten
in every class here what are you talking
three no three kids by 18 yeah I think
Mexicans got you beat okay maybe here
damn you have not lived in LA no I
haven't yeah not in like a high school
like that damn you'll be [ __ ] like
that they [ __ ] a lot here
[Music]
[Music]